und bei mir im studio ist jetzt peter
tiede peter was gilt denn jetzt fertig
aus einem risikogebiet zurückkomme also
noch gilt freiwillige tests und für
rückkehrer aus risikogebieten 14 tage in
die selbstisolation also heimische
quarantäne
ab anfang nächster woche soll dann
gelten was bundesgesundheitsminister
iren sparen gestern angekündigt hat
nämlich pflicht tests für rückkehrer aus
risikogebieten das heißt dann an
flughäfen zum beispiel dass dann dort
das stationen seien müssten sagt ganz
bewusst müssten weil ob das klappt ist
völlig unklar
und dann muss man da muss man sich dort
testen lassen und dann käme hinzu auch
an den seehäfen ebenfalls der station
und logischerweise an den deutschen
außengrenzen wenn man mit dem auto
zurückkehrt müsste rein theoretisch
jeder rückkehrer befragt werden wo
kommen sie her und wenn er aus einem
risikogebiet kommt oder ein risikogebiet
durchfahren hat oder dort übernachtet
hat dann wurde geltend es an der grenze
das heißt könnte es dann wieder zu einem
erneuten chaos kommen an den grenzen
also es kommt auf jeden fall zu einem
chaos wir haben jetzt schon chaos und
zwar ein jetzt schon 1 regelung dass wir
haben jetzt ein abstimmungskampf und
wenn kommt was angekündigt worden ist es
ist noch nicht beschlossen wenn kommt
was angekündigt worden ist dann haben
wir wieder grenzkontrollen und zwar
stand jetzt an einen deutschen
außengrenzen sind keine regulären
grenzkontrollen sondern der
straßenverkehr müsste dann auf
parkplätze abgeleitet werden und müsste
dann jedes auto rein gefragt wenn wo
kommen sie her ist die antwort ich komme
aus einem risikogebiet dann müsste man
sagen dort bis zum zum test anfang
weiter
das bedeutet grenzt aus und was muss ich
wissen oder beachten wenn ich jetzt aus
spanien zum beispiel wiederkomme oder
auch aus dem wolfgangsee aus dieser
region in österreich
da zeigt sich dann die absurdität die
wir momentan haben risikogebiete sind
nach der definition dass nach der
definition der bundesregierung nur ganze
länder
die sind auch gelistet also die kann man
sich angucken ist eine lange liste auf
der seite des us außenministeriums
arbeit zum beispiel spanien
man kann spanien nicht verlassen auf dem
landweg ohne durch ein risikogebiet zu
fahren nämlich die gesamte grenze nach
frankreich katalonien aragon und in der
waadt sind risikogebiete lokale hotspots
dort geht auch in london teilweise aber
spanien gilt nicht das wäre alles auch
der wolfgang sie die ganzen leute die
jetzt vom wolfgangsee gekommen wäre
nicht erfasst
nicht zum test und da gibt es jetzt die
ersten politiker die fordern dass das
geändert wird dass das die risikogebiete
auch lokalisiert werden dass man also
sagen kann wir aus einem hotspot in
einem land das nicht risikogebiet es
kommt also wolfgangsee bestimmte
regionen spaniens der muss auch zum
zwangs ist und wie teuer ist dann dieser
test und wer trägt die kosten dafür also
die tests kosten in deutschland
unterschiedlich viel das hängt wirklich
davon ab wo man ist und in welchem labor
getestet wird also zum beispiel kostet
der test am denen die stadthalle für
ihre für seine bürger anbietet die aus
risikogebieten zurückkommen am flughafen
leipzig der kostet 143 euro knapp sodass
ist vergleichsweise billig für deutsche
verhältnisse wenn man in berlin zum test
geht dann kann es sein wenn man wenn der
arzt oder die textstelle dann bei einem
bestimmten labor testen lässt kostet
alleine nur die labor nur der labortest
über 160 euro dann kommt noch mal die
regelleistung die sogenannte
regelleistung also der abstrich und die
beratung beim arzt noch mit dazu das ist
das 190 oder 200 euro
also das kann verdammt teuer werden und
wenn jetzt die familien oder die reisen
selber zahlen müssten also eine familie
fünfköpfige familie kommt aus der türkei
zurück dann wäre das sündhaft teuer
auf der anderen seite wer in ein
risikogebiet geflogen ist wusste ja
wohin fliegt es gab die aufforderung
machen sie urlaub in deutschland fahren
sie in länder die unbedenklich sind wir
jetzt in die türkei geflogen ist und zum
beispiel hat genau gewusst wohin fliegt
und er hat das risiko dann auch gekannt
aber herr spahn hat gestern gesagt die
tests sollen kostenlos sein für die
reisenden
das heißt wie nur bund länder oder die
krankenkassen die krankenkassen sagen
schon wir sind an der grenze das können
wir nicht tragen wir angeordnet der
bezahlt kanzleramtsminister brown hat
gestern abend auch erklärt wenn der
staat anordnete muss er das auch
bezahlen also stand jetzt wie gesagt
stand jetzt kann sich alles noch ändern
für den reisenden wohl kostenlos